freude herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video hat den titel gelesen die besten
und teuersten luxus fertig erstmal mit
wem könnte man das testen außer mit dem
youtube football so chris pieroth das
erste mal wurst echtes kompliment lasse
auf jeden fall verdient wir haben uns
drei sachen herausgepickt und das wird
immer dann der klassiker gegen die
luxusversion das ist so geil wir haben
quasi sofort kannst du dran ja wir haben
hier kerry king kennt glaube ich jeder
plastik gerade nicht kraft so an meine
schulzeit weil 100 jahre sind seinem
wagen gearbeitet hat war so ein ding im
kühlschrank 11 dass ich in einem
kühlschrank kam es nach hause war es
dann so kurz alleine geht es in die
mikrowelle machst das ding und genau da
setzt sich am computer und genießt erst
mal so eine halbe stunde ja folgen deine
haus hinaus so dieses curry den drüber
ich habe auch immer tot dazu gehört auch
hier ist die luxusversion also das
kostet acht oder neun euro ich gucke ich
werde euch ein gefäß kostet und dass
jetzt zwei euro das wird also auf jeden
fall ein interessantes einzigen 1 damit
stärken wir wir bereiten aber mal zu und
dann sehen wir uns zum test
hier wird schon das wasser im mund
zusammen wirklich war muss aber ehrlich
mal kurz festhalten ich glaube dass eine
größere portion oder wobei so vom
volumen her
man kann es nicht genau sagen sind auf
jeden fall dabei doch hier ist auf jeden
fall mehr wurst drin und jetzt kommen
wir schon zu einem wichtigen kommen sehr
sehr wichtig war vor dir liegen und zwar
bei kerry king ist auch nochmal
currypulver dabei hier leider nicht das
könnte schon drin sein für neun euro
aber vielleicht ich meine das ist ja
original berliner currywurst macht man
das nicht alle der 20 nicht haben aber
ich finde das irgendwie geil jetzt dass
das pulver das auch drauf kommen
wir machen erst mal den klassiker würde
sagen das ist schon das ist
ach das ist die schuld er finde ich auch
alter und jetzt wirklich noch so tost
reihen tippen und das so voll auskosten
das wäre wäre jetzt mein film jetzt muss
man nicht viel zu sagen jeder kennt
diese würstchen
was tun wenn ein fachbuch ich habe das
zu lange nicht vergessen sie also
zusätzlich irgendwie ist das ein
bisschen aus der zeit gefallen bin ich
aber wenn ich auch wenn ich auch ich
habe das bestimmt schon drei jahre nicht
gegessen mindestens locker das ist übel
sollte ich muss sie direkt reise ein
fachsimpeln
du hast die wurde war ja und du hast
einfach super schnell was zu essen wenn
wir hier mal schauen die sind alle so
richtig perfekt gleich und hier hast du
schon mehr so ein bisschen diese
handmade option halloween-feier system
das es denn ich glaube auch das hier ist
einfach mehr wurst als das hier darf
sind sehr gut sagen jaja das
wahrscheinlich mal bessere quali so
müsste es sein
jetzt müssen wir trotzdem den test
machen ich bin sehr sehr gespannt muss
ich wirklich sagen muss auch was geil
ist so besonders egal wo man im internet
liest ja dort ist die beste currywurst
die beste currywurst gibt es immer so
vom vom bau maria bauer marktweiber sind
dort so lecker hat ein halber liter
mario okay das muss probieren hat schon
eine andere textur so die wurst aber es
ist kroatischer so komplett also ich
finde auch dass es so eine curry muss
habe ich noch nie probiert ja und das
ist irgendwie merkwürdig weil currywurst
muss irgendwie so das sei fast schon
automatisch von so einem sonderbus die
die in der tomatensoße angerichtet wird
aber so dieses dieses deutsche
currywurst feeling hast du dir auch
nicht aber irgendwie so ein bisschen
mehr also in dem fall ist für mich der
klare gewinner kennt finde ich auch
klarer gewinner was mehr diesen
currywurst geschmack aber ist mir
schlecht und hier ist die wurst hat say
nummer eins ist ist wirklich gut aber
also die wurst ist auf jeden fall guidi
hat meist in der leiste textur die krank
zunächst ich ne gerade dann überlegst du
kannst dir davon holen da dem ding kerry
king ist ja also kerry king gewinnt hier
auch leben
dafür wirklich fast so ein bisschen
schwach unseren hitlers nur fühlst du
dich fühlst du dieses dieses süßlicher
thematik das könnte auch so ein ding aus
dem italienischen supermarkt luton
das heißt sie ziehen zum motto genauso
jetzt ist mein appetit erst richtig
damit scope ich bin deshalb jetzt
zwischen ein sehr leichtes wie die heute
beide aspekte
ich bin mir sicher dass das hier richtig
gut wird guckt euch das mal ganz kurz
und hier ist der klassiker varela
polonaise ihr seht hier so sehr thematik
so ein bisschen dicklich und halt echt
nicht viel fleisch ja genau und hier
drüben das sieht aus wie eine richtige
boden ist gegen die richtige bei dieser
umfrage zeigen was da langhans ist das
hat glaube ich neun euro gekostet
vielleicht seien preiswert drehen und
dann sieht man nämlich was das besondere
ist ohne konservierungsstoffe
ich muss auch sagen also eine polonaise
für neun euro für zwei personen wenn ihr
richtig gut schmeckt das geht vorher
klar wenn das festival restaurant - aber
im endeffekt bin ich selber machen
willst und gutes hat und alles benutzt
dann tröstet auch deutlich mehr ist da
garantiert auch von daher ich bin sehr
gespannt wir mal so zwei häufig sind ein
mit dem klassiker mit varela und den
anderen mit der langhans luxusvariante
und ich kann nur soviel sagen man riecht
richtig dort in rotwein die riecht halt
einfach wirklich leute ja richtig die
rief richtig ergab das mich aber heute
auch an so einem tag errichten wo mein
hunger leer will sie so hoch her
hier will hier luxus also man sieht
schon deutlich weniger fleisch hier ist
das so sehr eine bolognese soße ist ja
klassischerweise baku also eine
fleischlose genau und da sieht man hier
total und hier weniger aber wir haben
uns quasi schon vorentschieden wir
müssen gucken ob der geschmackstest auch
mit kommerz ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
dass barilla keine chance hat wir haben
auch gleich noch heute so eines lepper
einfach 1 18 eur fertiggericht das ist
richtig klasse das muss sagen das sieht
richtig viel versprechend glaube ich
auch kann man essen wenig fleisch
sehr süß irgendwie eine polonaise sehr
süß wenig fleisch aber wenn man keine
generell wenig wenig inhalt so ja aber
ich glaube man kann es dazu kommen dass
du auch so praktiziert also man für den
charakter hätte schnell gehen muss ist
okay wenn man auf jeden fall auf den
geschmack jetzt gucken wir uns mal die
luxus variante hier bin ich richtig
gespannt bin aus super gespannt könnte
könnte trotzdem bisschen flüssiger seien
ja ja also es geht nicht auf die nudeln
übungen dann wollen einfach jetzt doch
ist wirklich nicht einfach nur noch dass
ich dachte damals verschieden so klar
okay
logisch dass 1000 mal besser aber ich
habe wirklich das gefühl wenn man beide
sauce mischen würde dann hätte man so
ein gutes ergebnis sondern auch das
tapet das was der für und umgekehrt hier
hast du viele zutaten etwas worauf du
kaum kann hier eher weniger aber dafür
fehlt der hier einfach so ein bisschen
mehr flüssigkeit als ich glaube auch so
beide zusammen schlägt sogar am besten
was ist hier jetzt der gewinner
schwierig so schwierig wie wollen wir
gewinner definieren wirklich so vom
geschmack geschmack oder vom gesamt am
ende tresor geschmack okay jetzt wird
der geschmack ja dann ist die dose hier
auf mögliche aussagen und vielleicht
auch besser aber trotzdem nicht
unbedingt eine riesen empfehlungen bans
preis kommt vom verkäufer also auch hier
wieder wenn sie euch interessiert
probiert ist eine empfehlung ja ich
werde jetzt menschen die welt wird aus
hessen ob die dann wirklich perfekt ist
werden wir es erkennen können deutlich
dafür und suppen ruhig in der ersten
sekunde wo wir die currywürste dazu
bereit habe es dann direkt meinen pulli
versorgt kommt jetzt wirklich in der
richtigen balance am nächsten so ist
perfekt ja so süß ist die ags mit
parmesan darüber dass das spiel aber für
die vergleichbarkeit nicht nur weil ich
vergessen habe
es ist ein schönes freunde müssen
der somit allen leuten zusammen an einem
so 10 km tisch sitzen und einfach
schließlich amten auto einfach das gleis
in hessen quatschen oder auch überlegt
man wie man so ein geist special man
machen könnte man wirklich einfach nur
so mit allen leuten so ist wird
schwierig und teuer
allerdings hat aber echt gedacht dass
ich gleich mir wenn ich eine million
autos hoffentlich habe dass mir mein fuß
statt miete und dann einfach so ein
großstädte fahrt 23 und spenden den
leuten also essen schenkt ja das top
maria ist weiter weg jetzt haben wir
hier in der linken ecke 60 altersgruppe
um einkauf lauter werden flat ich habe
es irgendwie folge für das ist wirklich
nur 60 und hier haben wir wagner gulasch
da war sie fürchten das feinste vom
feinen und hier steht einfach so lecker
gulasch sein das ist ein fertiggericht
und die behaupten die setzen den
standard für gulasch braucht man muss
wirklich sagen es riecht sehr heftig
also man kriegt wirklich so krasse
hundefutter weil ja genau das ist es ja
auch wenn es wahrscheinlich gar nicht
schlecht schmeckt und auch
wahrscheinlich super vielen haushalten
zu finden ist ja eher würde ich es mir
nie kaufen würde ich mir auch nicht
haben ich bin vor allem gespannt aber
auch auf mikrowellen spätzle
da kann es mal probieren wir haben bis
die komplett normale sind sehr gut
wie finde ich bin stark was man zuerst
eigentlich dass hier nicht einmal der
klassiker wie weit das jetzt auch nicht
wirklich sicher ist trotzdem sehr
gespannt nein so war es noch so nicht
wahrhaben nicht richtig heiß zu essen ja
gar nicht also so mit kantinen gulasch
zu vergleichen was tun wenn irgendwo in
der kantine isst und gulasch ist dann
ist es ja auch so dass reifenlager
genommen aber ich finds halt einfach
nicht geil das so generell ist cooler
ist nicht so mein lieblings ja ja ja
aber das hier könnte sehr gut aus weil
hier auch ich glaube sowieso
pfifferlinge rahmen so sieht man bei uns
kostet das man muss sich ganz kurz vor
augen 1 18 eur 3 eur 59 18 euro
die hast du eine beilage radio ist halt
das teuerste vielleicht die welt nicht
und dementsprechend kostet das
auslastungsproblemen gleichzeitig will
ich bin sehr gespannt ob das richtig ist
dass er mit 321 und direkte dachte man
bei vielleicht auf das status zu stücken
vielleicht der welt
ja es ist aber deutlich wert ist
superzahl ist sehr fein sohin geschmack
nicht auch durch diese rahmen soße sie
so sein mega ja nicht auch super lecker
das gleiche hat auch schon einen
angenehmen geschmack aber es ist auch
wieder kein welten und gar nicht ich
dachte wirklich dass wird ich habe schon
mal wenn du daran beißt dann trifft das
gleich stift ja schon und das ist es
trotzdem
also ich hätte nicht gedacht dass es so
trocken ist so das ist das ist nicht
viel zarter als das hier und das sind
wirklich eigentlich welt angleicht
qualität das schmeckt deutlich besser
das schmeckt auch recht gut für gulasch
aber es ist halt leider nicht das
erlebnis was ich mir ich habe nicht als
du das gemacht das dachte ich sowohl das
wird sie next level business class die
ja ja ja so ist nun fertig ist einfach
einen hinflug von sehr lecker mit den
späten aber das fleisch enttäuschten
bist dann muss man sagen das ist ein
krasses fertiggericht ja alles fertig
ist supergut auch der eindeutige
gewinner auf jeden fall da hätte mehr
gehen können und kein bisschen traurig
finde ich auch damit wir nicht so
traurig sind leicht dieses video finden
nein schade auf jeden fall bei block
vorbei und schreibt vielleicht mal
fertig gerichtet wenn ihr welche kennt
die in der höherklassigen version super
krass viel besser sind schreibt in die
kommentare weil dann würde ich die gerne
auch noch aus hessentag ich glaube da
gibt es ein echtes bestimmten riesigen
markt für teure fertig
wir nehmen auch die tage noch ein video
für rob auf also auf jeden fall die
augen auf den beinen halten und wir
sehen